das tagesgespräch bei phoenix mit gregor
gysi dem außenpolitischen sprecher der
fraktion die linke im bundestag größe
ganz herzlich in berlin im home office
oder und daher komme ja sehr schön also
fangen wir mal so an wahrscheinlich
haben sie jetzt durch die tatsache dass
joe biden präsident des weniger
potenzial sich aufzuregen oder auf jeden
fall das wichtigste kündigt die andere
kultur auch die andere gesprächskultur
das heißt er wird auch mit anderen
staatsoberhäuptern oder anderen
vertreterinnen und vertretern aus ihr
verschiedene gesellschaften anders
umgehen als das amt gemacht hat
erinnerte er immer an so verwöhnten aber
meist seitlich auch wenig bewusstsein
ausgestatteten jungen den man immer
einen psychologen gewünscht hat aber man
hat dem amerikanischen volk nicht
gewünscht das ist ihr präsident ist aber
so was haben die amerikaner so gewählt
jetzt haben sie die beiden gewählt auch
wenn es knapp war egal er ist es jetzt
viele sagen jetzt wird es langweiliger
was verlässlicher was sagen sie
wie wird es jetzt ich will ihre
verlässlichkeit nicht langweilig ich
finde das sind keine vokabeln die
zusammenpassen
das wichtigste ist natürlich auch wie
ist sein verhältnis zu den anderen nato
staaten wird er weiter darauf drängen
dass wir immer mehr aufrüsten kann man
ihn vielleicht davon überzeugen dass
werden wir mehr aufrüsten auf alle
anderen länder mehr aufrüsten dass man
vielleicht einen anderen weg gehen muss
ich freue mich zum beispiel dass das
abkommen mit russland über die
begrenzung der atomraketen der cetera
wieder in kraft getreten wurde durch
putin und ihn das haben sie sehr schnell
vereinbart
und ich hoffe dass das eine
herangehensweise sein wird das zweite
was ich hoffe ist dass er erkennt das
ist laut der menschheitsprobleme gibt ob
ich die soziale frage nehme oder die
ökologische nachhaltigkeit
das heißt wir müssen auch mit der
sogenannten dritten welt ganz anders
umgehen
letztlich hat er gesagt er will härte
gegenüber china und russland zeigen ich
weiß auch nicht was er meint er hat ja
auch wieder gesagt zusammenarbeit mit
china ich hoffe dass sich das verhältnis
verbessert ich habe
wenn ich etwas von der sozialdemokratie
gelernt habe dann was die politik des
wandels durch annäherung also den ddr
hat sich durch die ernährung sehr
verändert die socken und hat damals
sogar sacharow ausgelassen auch
entschieden da gab es dann ergebnisse
etc
also wenn das seine linie wird und ich
hoffe auch die vieler anderer länder
dann könnten wir vielleicht auch
veränderungen in russland erreichen also
statt sanktionen und immer mehr härte
zeigen lieber wandel durch annäherung
also die sagen wir mal merkel linie
merkel war immer unentschlossen
sie wusste weil ich sie wollte das eine
und das andere sie hat zu versucht bei
der ukraine zu vermitteln gleichzeitig
weiß ich immer sehr präsentation aber
ich habe festgestellt dass sanktionen
führen nur dazu dass sich die länder
einbringen kann
sie reagieren ja nicht darauf indem sie
das abschalten was man gerade kritisiert
sondern das hat eigentlich eine
gegenreaktion deren wandel durch
annäherung ist viel besser
man sagt na gut wir könnten die
sanktionen aufheben aber wir müssen uns
auch stück entgegenkommen und so weiter
wenn man das dann diplomatisch macht
kann man auch das eine oder andere
hinbekommen ich bin ja auch mit vielen
dingen in russland und in china
unzufrieden aber ich merke man erreicht
keine änderung in dem man mal härte
zeigt dann werden die nur moggi dann
kann ich mal sagen von der schule zu
bleiben
das wort da sind wir jetzt automatisch
schon obwohl ich später dazukommen
wollte bei nordstream 2 und wir sind bei
navalny und das gebaren der russischen
regierung was haben sie dafür eine
haltung was sagen sie was da jetzt vor
sich geht in sachen in der wanne wie
läuft das aus ihrer sicht also ich halte
das für völlig falsch
nachdem er nach einem mordversuch zurück
hält ihn als erstes einzusperren und
dann die bewährung zu widerrufen
dabei ist ja das gericht sogar über den
antrag der staatsanwaltschaft hinaus
gegangen
das halte ich für falsch und ich kann
nur hoffen dass ein höheres gericht das
korrigiert und vor allen dingen
natürlich hat man den eindruck sie
wollen nur dass er sich nicht mehr
öffentlich äußern
da darf natürlich auch nicht
beschuldigung aussprechen die ja gar
nicht belegen kann das ist wieder fest
dass ich merke wie sie
das duo zuspitzt hier wäre im wieder
diplomatie angesagt wir schicken unsere
botschafter in die gerichtsverhandlung
andere länder machen das aus aber dann
habe ich ja die reaktion des russischen
außenministeriums gelesen aber auch zum
teil sarkastisch etc
dann halten die uns die gelb besten und
vieles andere vor
und ich glaube auch dass wir hier mehr
diplomatie brauchen erreicht man
vielleicht auch die partner wollen ich
will natürlich dass er sofort entlassen
wird auch die demonstranten dass bei den
demonstranten muss man natürlich
folgendes wissen sie haben wegen der
pandemie die demonstration verboten
das war schon bevor aber nie zurückkam
und dann haben sich die leute natürlich
nicht daran gehalten und ich darf daran
erinnern wir in deutschland haben
auch demonstrationen verboten bis das
bundesverfassungsgericht gesagt hat
nicht ganz so geht es nicht ihr könnt
zwar auflagen machen usw usw also diese
ausnahme situation haben wir natürlich
bereit
und wenn die polizei so brutal vorgeht
verbundes teile ich das immer man hat
seine übermacht mit schlagstöcken etc
nicht so auszunutzen wie das dort
geschehen ist weiß allerdings auch in
anderen ländern geschieht also wenn sie
sagen da muss man diplomatisch daran
dass es natürlich dann innenpolitische
angelegenheit wie polizei umgeht mit
verhaftungen mit demonstranten und
dergleichen und welche gesetzeslagen
gelten aber wenn sie sagen diplomatie
gewinnen
gerade weil es eine innenpolitische
frage ist müssen wir über außenpolitik
versuchen etwas einfluss auf die
innenpolitik zu bekommen das hat die
politik wandel durch annäherung klar
geschafft so wurde in der ddr was
glauben sie was ich durch den
grundlagenvertrag usw alles in der ddr
geändert hätte ist diese diplomatie
nicht gegeben wäre es auch nicht zu
diesen veränderungen gekommen
das lassen wir mal so stehen wir haben
ja weiter unsere ddr-vergangenheit jeder
auf seine weise
aber welches gerade angesprochen hatte
da muss man dann auf nord stream 2 schon
auch zu sprechen kommen gehört das zu
einem diplomatischen mitteln sein so das
ist ein druck der da aufgebaut wird der
darf gar nicht sein oder sagen sie
nord stream zwar sollte überhaupt nicht
laufen also das ist ja nun seit jahren
aufgebaut worden wir haben ja schon
milliarden ausgegeben für diese
erdgasleitung
und vor allen dingen der satz klingt ja
auch so furchtbar werden wir das nehmen
was herr du sachen immer wollten
das heißt natürlich dass wir ökologisch
noch fragt würden wir das erdgas
bekommen
die behauptung dass deutschland von
russland hinsichtlich der energie
abhängig wird ist nun eindeutig
widerlegt worden
selbst werden dass gar nicht
funktioniert sind wir nicht in der
energie abhängig aber es geht ja nicht
nur um uns ich glaube es geht noch um
elf weitere eu-staaten sie ja auch das
erdgas darüber beziehen wollen und
nachdem man so viel geld ausgegeben hat
jetzt bei den letzten metern zu sein
nehmen wir machen das nicht das geht
nicht da muss die frau merkel ein
bisschen hart sein sowohl gegenüber
marco mit der ja auch gegen ein hot
strings fast als auch gegenüber den usa
vor allen dingen kann man diesen ländern
immer nachweisen
soweit sie ein ökonomisches interesse
hatten haben sie es immer durchgesetzt
und auch auf bedenken aus deutschland
keine rücksicht genommen und jetzt muss
das ding vollendet werden damit dann
auch ruhe herrscht diesbezüglich und
dann sollte man vielleicht die politik
diesbezüglich stärker koordinieren als
das vorher der fall war
überhaupt machen dass man ihnen dazu
gehört im außenministerium und dem
kanzleramt für diese ideen einreichung
wir müssen wir noch ganz kurz zum
schluss reden über das was da heute
ansteht deutsch-französischen
sicherheits- und verteidigungsrat makro
merkel unterhalten sich es geht
umrüstung im grunde genommen oder was
erwarten sie da na ja es geht um rüstung
und es geht auch um den plan
wahrscheinlich eine europäische armee
aufzustellen
ich weiß nicht wieso die eu invasions
fähig werden muss ich möchte dass die
welt wieder lernen anders zu denken
wissen sie was mich wirklich stört man
hat nicht mitbekommen das ende des
kalten krieges und damit verbundene neue
aufgabenstellung so sehr wie heute gab
es selten menschheitsfragen die gelöst
werden muss und militärisch kriegt man
sie nicht gelöst was mich stört und ich
hoffe dass sich beide darüber
verständigen könnten ist dass fast alle
regierungen nur noch militärisch decken
sind mal die regierungsarbeit schade
sagt wir haben wir es geschafft berg
karabach militärisch
was sagt die türkei wir müssen einmal
schien auch völkerrechtswidrig in syrien
wegen der kunden erzählt ich will jetzt
gar nicht an die einzelnen begründungen
gehen sondern ich will nur sagen es wird
so stark militärisch gedacht und
eigentlich müssten deutschland und
frankreich mal ein anderes denken in den
vordergrund stellen und sagen hört auf
damit wir müssen wieder zur diplomatie
zur politik zurückkehren nicht alles
militärisch lösen und insofern gefallen
mir die anfangs setzte von präsident
beiden ja das vielleicht nicht so gewalt
wie ich es jetzt interpretiere
aber man kann es eben so interpretieren
tatsächlich zurück zur politik zurück
zur diplomatie
da haben sie als meine gedanken lesen
ich wollte es selbst nicht sagen
wir sind der ausgangspunkt unseres
gesprächs zurück also steht uns jetzt
mal eine ruhigere großartige zukunft im
westlichen bündnis bevor auch im konzert
der vielen großen blöcke dieser welt
oder wird es weiterhin ruhig bleiben
zum beispiel wird sich bin doch jetzt
nicht wahnsinnig und gebe keine prognose
ab die sie mir deinen tal widerlegen
können aber ich sage mal folgendes ist
besteht zumindest hoffnung dass
tatsächlich mehr kultur und diplomatie
einzieht dass wir vielleicht wirklich
aufhören nur militärisch zu denken dass
die anderen gebiete wieder eine andere
bedeutung bekommen als sie die tore
hatten die hoffnung will ich nicht
aufgeben allerdings muss sich
einschränken dazu sagen ich bin ein
zweckoptimist und deshalb versuche ich
immer auch die zukunft optimistischer
als zu sehen als sie dann vielleicht
kommt dann freuen wir uns über diesen
zweck optimismus teilen wer und ich sage
danke schön für das gespräch danke nach
berlin gregor gysi wünsche ihnen auch
alles gute